in light of recent bullying cases and
you know teen suicides that have been
out recently what do you want people to
take away from west of Memphis regarding
groupthink scapegoating and mobbing just
how dangerous and absolutely deadly it
can be in some situations you know this
this went so far that our people were
literally trying to murder me simply
because i did not fit in in a community
and it wasn't one specific person the
way we sometimes think that bullying can
be this was an entire community and not
only did it lead to this group think not
only did it lead to railroading us but
it also led to an actual murder murderer
being allowed to walk the streets for
almost 20 years just because they were
so focused on us Laurie any thoughts
because you returned or you went to the
community in the 90s right to a canoe
the case my thoughts came from New York
and well I actually was raised in the
south so I understood that that's one of
the reasons I felt an affinity for
Damien because as growing up not that I
was a goth kid or anything but I thought
differently than the rest of my
community which was very religious you
know fundamentalist and and and it's
tough being in that position and that's
one of the reasons Damien and I feel so
strongly about this film as we do want
people to be inspired to take steps to
do the right thing what would you say
about people who live in a metaphorical
prison you know you were in what
solitary confinement for ten years
you're just in prison for almost 20 a
lot of people live lives where they're
in a metaphorical prison although
they're free to walk the street so now
that you've had this taste of freedom
for what a year and a half or so what's
your take on that because you both
studied so much about alternative ways
of thinking I think it's one of the
things that we hope people take away
from this is we don't want people to
come away from it down hearted or
feeling like they've been beaten down
or you know a sense of Darkness however
cover them we want them to come away
from this film with with hope and
inspiration seeing that it is possible
in the face of what other people think
are unbeatable odds it is still possible
to rise up and overcome that you know we
tell people now that you can't give up
the things you love the things that are
meaningful and the things that make your
life magical just because other people
are putting pressure on you or trying to
hurt you for them because if you do then
you may as well be dead anyway you're
not really living that's an that is such
an amazing question because people often
say how did you all how did you survive
all those years you must have been so
miserable it was hard work and it was
there was a lot of grief that they mean
and I were always happier than most of
the people that we knew who were living
lives where they weren't living and
that's what I mean really if people
could just get that from from our story
that that alone would be amazing to get
someone to just see that you could even
live move your life thank you thank you